peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tulle et brive sous les eaux la corrèze
débordé surtout son cours c'est par là
que débute à la catastrophe qui devait
atteindre lui département du centre
la crue fut brutale et violente et les
eaux en se retirant laisse apparaître
toute l'ampleur du désastre car l'eau
quand elle n'a pas détruit à tout gâter
et tous corrompus dans les campagnes
c'est par milliers qu'on peut compter
les bestiaux victimes de l'inondation et
en certains endroits c'est le cheptel
entier qu'on devra reconstituer
[Musique]
et quant au reste le désastre est sans
précédent dans six régions voient faire
et coupez pas emporté routes rompu si le
barrage de chant de grêle a tenu bon
malgré une fissure sa menace a pesé
pendant deux jours sur la région
environnante comme un nouveau mal passé
à aubusson les eaux de la creuse se sont
déversés dans la ville entraînant à
brive comme à terrasson comme dans des
dizaines de villages
on a vécu des heures dramatiques sans
ravitaillement sans électricité sans
communication coupée du monde
les célèbres atelier de tapisserie qui
font depuis des siècles la gloire
d'aubusson sont gravement atteints
que restera-t-il des travaux en cours
des collections de l'aisne aujourd'hui
salies décomposer perdu ce désastre est
le plus grave du genre que la france ait
subie depuis 39 ans il faut pour
l'instant loger des milliers de sans
abri ravitailler des quartiers entiers
[Musique]
et il ya encore maintenant que l'eau est
partie la boue le 11ème anniversaire de
la république populaire de chine a été
célébré avec un avec le déploiement
populaire traditionnel dans la tribune
officielle monsieur xunlight chef du
gouvernement chinois au milieu de ses
nombreux invités étrangers a pu voir
défiler quelques 500 mille personnes
les éléments armés ayant figuré sous la
forme des milices de la capitale bien
que ce défilé était annoncé comme devant
être strictement civil
cette faction guerrière s'était vite la
place aux fleurs et aux rubans car le
défilé de ce onzième anniversaire se
placer sous le signe officiel du sourire
ce n'est qu'en dernière heure que le
cortège pervis sa belle ordonnance mais
c'était en faveur de mao tsé toung
[Applaudissements]
il fallait bien que ce soit par le
mémorial du vercors que le général de
gaulle commence son voyage à travers sa
voix et dauphiné on sait ce qu évoque ce
nom d'un massif perdues dont la
résistance a fait l'un des hauts lieux
de notre temps après cette visite honors
héroïque
le président de gaulle est allé parler
aux vivants à grenoble d'abord où malgré
certaines consignes d'abstention la
foule n'en est pas moins à la fois
enthousiaste et amicale
grenoble a une spécialité son
laboratoire d'étude démarrer le
président cifit expliqué sur un modèle
réduit de 14 mètres de diamètre le jeu
démarre et de la manche et la
réalisation de l'usiné marémotrice de la
rance
et puis c'est la rapide revue des villes
de dauphine est de savoir thonon les
bains où le président dit la france doit
être elle même et cela est vrai sur tous
les terrains
[Musique]
même si une foule dense et chaleureuse
manifeste du plus près qu'elle peut sa
confiance au chef de l'état
annecy où il déclare l'europe doit se
bâtir et s'unir
mais chaque pays doit garder sa
personnalité et son âme
[Applaudissements]
chambéry enfin où les élan populaire
font oublier le mauvais temps chambéry
où il jette cette attelle je demande aux
français de me soutenir et de bd de ne
pas se déchirer en passion est en excès
contraire la leçon de la savoie
ma vie l'attaquant règle menée par
monsieur krotov contre le secrétaire
général des nations unies monsieur en
marche elle aura sans doute constitué
l'un des moments les plus étonnants de
la session de l'onu le premier voulant
tacler le second à la démission
le second s'y refusant au mécontentement
du premier il faut plus de courage pour
rester que pour partir dire à monsieur h
je reste
en prenant le départ des 6 heures de
paris première en date sur une piste
aménagée à l'aéroport d'orly c'est un
véhicule ont consacré un petit événement
l'adoption en france d'un sport qui fait
fureur en amérique le karting
500 clubs de créer en six mois c'est
aujourd'hui en france huit mille adeptes
officielle qui courent à 50 km/heure sur
ces bolides dotée de quatre roues d'un
châssis d'un volant et d'amateurs
justement le moteur à 100 ans
c'est en effet au début de 1860 qui
était déposée à paris le brevet d'un
premier moteur à explosion
le nom de l'inventeur jean-joseph
etienne le noir son auteur de thé déjà
de l'essentiel une bougie bien entendu
et des pistons entraînante avis gros
qu'un ne fonctionnait pas encore à
l'essence mais au gaz
en tout cas il fonctionnait si on
s'entend les progrès ont été sensibles
qu'il ne nous fasse pas oublié le nom de
lenoir et donnons lui une pensée en
découvrant le moteur à pistons rotatifs
l'une des curiosités du 47ème salon de
l'automobile qui a inauguré le général
de gaulle ce salon du reste sans
nouveauté fracassante contrat plutôt
comme celui des perfectionnements et du
confort recherché chez par par exemple
la pl 17 arbore cette année une quantité
de perfectionnement ces améliorations
vont jusqu'à l'éclairage individuels
prévus pour le passager
[Musique]
davantage de place pour les bagages
même préoccupation chez volks wagen
troisième constructeur mondial
d'automobiles
où l'on constate également des
agrandissements côté kof
à une boîte de vitesses entièrement
synchronisée au même stade la karmann
ghia qui réunit les avantages de la
voiture de sport sans en comporter les
inconvénients le domaine des poids
lourds se signale par un paradoxe
le poids plume de 10 tonnes pendus à des
ballons
à côté de ce camion berliet présente
aussi un 4 tonnes véritablement léger
lui qui se veut la bonne à tout faire
des grandes et petites entreprises
[Musique]
rayon tourisme peugeot demeure fidèle à
sa jeanne 404
mais sans préjudice pour la 403 dans le
modèle berline diesel qui offre le
kilomètre à moitié prix reste la voiture
de tourisme la plus économique de sa
catégorie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à signaler encore pour les délicats ce
modèle américain qui comporte un volant
mobiles pour faciliter l'installation du
conducteur
sans oublier cet autre confort n'est ce
pas philippe l'est qui permet les
voyages au long cours sans sortir de
chez soi
[Applaudissements]
le porte avions lancé par la france
depuis la guerre le clemenceau qui
achève sa préparation dans l'atlantique
attendait la dernière partie de son
armement les étendards cap
c'est maintenant chose faite les
premiers de ces appareils viennent d'y
accomplir leur s est proche parent du
mirage iv détenteur du record du monde
des 1000 km puisqu'il appartient à la
famille des appareils construits par la
générale aéronautique marcel dassault
l'étendard 4 possède des qualités qui en
font l'avion a embarqué d'attaqué de
chasse le mieux aptes à assurer la
liberté de l'air en méditerranée
[Musique]
avec cette série de catapultage et
d'appontage réussi la marine française
vient de marquer un nouveau point
c'est désormais un fait acquis étendard
et clemenceau sont assurés de faire bon
ménage
[Musique]